[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled spatial transcriptomic
profiling of spiny projection neurons in
the mouse striatum
my name is elizabeth schneider
senior global marketing manager and i'll
be your moderator for today's event that
is part of the 10th annual neuroscience
virtual conference
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and sponsored by
nana string
for more information about nana string
please visit our website
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using the new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right hand side of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby of the event
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker allison
van scoyk
senior product enablement scientist
administering technologies
thank you so much for being here allison
we're looking forward to your
presentation
okay thanks elizabeth for the
introduction today i'll be talking about
using spatial transcriptomics for
detailed localized profiling of specific
cell types in focal areas within the
mouse brain by presenting data from both
a project conducted internally at
nanostring as part of our spatial organ
atlasing efforts and another project
described clearly in the title here that
was looking into spiny project
projection neurons in the mouse straight
adam that was done in collaboration with
dr caitlin romano and dr ellen hess at
the emory university school of medicine
the field of spatial biologies is in
spatial biology is in many ways very new
as the genomics field has evolved from
using bulk onto single cell to spatial
methodologies within the last 15 years
to understand the dynamic gene
expressions at play in development and
disease
it's clear that cell types organization
and gene expression patterns play a
critical role in how genes orchestrate
development and disease and really only
spatial methodologies allow us to
collectively ask the questions what are
the cell types how are they organized
and what are the gene expression
patterns at play or in this case allow
us to look fully at the the fruit tart
instead of its individual components or
a blended product
now interestingly i think the
neuroscience community is really well
ahead of the game and realizing the
importance
of spatial transcriptomics and also in
execution so allen institute for brain
science was founded in 2003 and one of
their first priorities was mapping gene
expression throughout the mouse and
human brains this
was an amazing amount of work and a
resource used by many i know
in the neuroscience community still
today including myself of course along
with their increasing number of other
databases and resources these are
incredible resources the scale
throughput and expense there's a whole
institute that dedicated to these outlet
efforts not really practical for
most investigators
to use the same methodologies to conduct
genomics experiments in this same way in
the context of disease or using a
disease model of interest it's certainly
far from the originally intended
scope of
the alicing efforts now excitingly
almost 15 years after this first facial
transcriptomics experiment was published
spatial transcriptomics was named as
nature methods method of the year in
2020 which in many ways means that
today's spatial transcriptomics methods
are available to any researcher to use
to better understand spatial gene
expression in the context of disease or
in a given disease model
so this is what uh spatial
transcriptomic profiling looked like in
2006 so essentially the atlas released
in 2006 it has nc2 hybridization images
for over 20 000 genes throughout the
mouse brain at 200 micron
intervals so we can see in the bottom
right side of the slide
an example of the gene drd2 and this is
just a subset of the different coronal
planes that were profiled in this effort
so we can clearly see the expression
pattern of this in single transcript
throughout the striatum
as get deeper in
into the brain now for any one of these
given coronal planes that we're looking
at there are roughly 20 000 in c2
hybridization images on that same exact
claim showing transcript by transcript
spatial
spatial
resolution
spatial expression with high resolution
in each of these images now importantly
this is spatial but it's not necessarily
cell type specific so we see drd
expression in
our transcripts in the stratum but we
can't necessarily associate them with
the with a given cell type from this
resource still amazing tool amazing
reference to use now
15
years later we've come a long way in
making these facial methods accessible
for targeted whole transcriptome level
experiments so the experiments that i'm
going to discuss today use the geomex
digital spatial profiler
which enables users to visualize their
tissue select regions features
or cell types within regions of interest
for whole transcriptome profiling using
in this case our mouse whole
transcriptome but we also have human
whole transcriptome assay now step by
step how this works is that
you would first stain your slides
with fluorescently labeled antibodies or
you could use in c2 hybridization probes
as well
along with our geomics oligoconjugated
rna detection probes
these are hybridization probes that are
conjugated
to a barcode or that have a barcode
conjugated that includes the uv
photocleavable linker so essentially
once the reagents are on the slide
the instrument will take an image of
that slide you can select your regions
of interest on
on the tissue
and then the instrument will use uv
light to
cleave the barcodes in any region of
interest designated
on
the given sample
so at the end of the experiments uh
sorry these are these are then collected
into a 96 well plate and then at the end
of the experiment
for whole transcriptome assays the the
barcodes are read out on an illumina
sequencer
now the magic behind the system really
lies in the incorporation of the digital
micromere device that's sort of shown
here in this cartoon type of
of image there are actually two of these
in the geomex instrument each containing
about a million
teeny tiny mirrors
that
enable
the system
to shape the uv light to directly match
the biology in a given tissue section so
in this example we have
an image of a region of interest from a
mouse brain selected from mouse brain
stained with three different neuronal
subpopulation markers along with a
microglia marker
and the instrument can make a mask based
on the fluorescent signal from each of
these different markers
and then the dmd can
shape the uv light
directly to that mask to enable to
specifically illuminate each population
separately and collect a whole
transcriptome worth of information
from each of the different populations
so this is just one way of targeted
transcriptomic profiling in the brain
here we've listed multiple other
approaches that can be taken so
we can use geometric profiling
which enables the fine selection of
different histological features within a
given tissue here we show
the selection of different cortical
layers in a mouse brain
can use segmentation
which can enable or where contiguous
features can be selected um or separated
using fluorescence uh in this case we're
looking at granule cells versus the
purkinje layer in the cerebellum rare
cell or cell type specific segmentation
as i showed on the previous slide a
common application in the neuroscience
community
is to use a contouring type of approach
where a specific feature is identified
on the tissue section
in this case a beta amyloid plaque
identified
and then
can contour out from that feature on the
tissue
at a specific distance to profile the
micro
environment around uh the plaque
um sort of a step by in step-by-step
increments
we can also do gridded profiling or even
combine
gridding with an alternate with another
approach outlined here so you could
profile the pink neurons within this
this image here on the far right for
example independently
of the remaining tissue in each
box shown on the grid
now
with so much flexibility it can
sometimes make it challenging to design
a good experiment
especially as these tools for generating
high plex spatial transcriptomic data
are becoming more mainstream and
relatively easy to use
so one of the things that nanostring has
recently put forward to help facilitate
the spatial biology community is our
spatial organ atlas which is a publicly
available reference data repository for
demonstrating new paradigms in spatial
organ research
thus far the database consists of five
human organs we have lymph node colon
pancreas
kidney
and human brain along with the mouse
brain
data that i will be sharing today and we
have plans to expand to include
additional organs for both human and
mouth
one of the primary purposes of this
resource is to establish best practices
for spatial transcriptomics across
different organs and tissue types
so i'll briefly walk through the mouse
brain
data set for the spatial organ alice
today as an example of different ways to
utilize spatial transcriptomic profiling
and importantly to visualize and
interpret the results
i'll follow this up with a great example
from within the neuroscience community
to show how spatial transcriptomics is
being used for targeted
research questions
so i'll start here with the spatial
organ atlas
on this slide we can see an example
brain image from the mouse facial organ
atlas
experiment sold data sets so the
reference data in
the soa as we call it is from four male
60 day old c57 black six
j mice we profiled the same region from
mouse to mouse most of the data i'll
show here today
is going to be from a single mouse and
that's the way that we put the stories
together
on our website but the data for all four
mouse if
all four mice is available for download
at our website and can be explored
from there
for the geomics experiments
we visualized neuronal nuclei using nu n
that's shown here in magenta
we visualize astrocytes using gfap shown
in cyan
and microglia
using iba1 in yellow along with a
nuclear stain
the different regions with the shaded
overlays in the image are the different
regions of interest that were collected
for this experiment so in the bottom
right cartoon you can see all of the
different areas of the brain that were
profiled these areas were aligned on
this coronal plane that we imaged same
plane for all four mice
we aligned the regions using a different
atlas from the allen brain institute the
anatomical reference atlas that we see
in the top right
now as i mentioned selecting good rois
can be one of the most challenging
aspects of targeted transcriptomics
experiments
brain is very complex mouse brain
contains 100 million cells organized
into
at least 461 recognizable
three-dimensional structures
as annotated in the anatomical outlets
from the brain institute i stress
recognizable here because we're learning
that there
are
likely more than
more regions than those that are
visually distinct and i think this will
discover more and more especially as
facial biology becomes more mainstream
for the spatial organ atlas experiments
we sampled from structures that are of
common interest across multiple disease
areas in the neuroscience community
one of the great things about geomics is
that you don't need to select a single
roi strategy
for this experiment we used both
geometric and cell type specific
segmentation approaches
so on this slide i've highlighted only
the geometric rois that were collected
for this experiment you can see here
that we use polygons to trace distinct
histological features like the cortical
layers
or the dente gyrus of the hippocampus
shown here in this magnified image
now again the geomex instrument can use
that digital micromere device i see in
the cartoon to specifically illuminate
these features based on my morphology
in many regions such as the amygdala
hypothalamus catapultamine various
thalamic nuclei
we've placed geometric circles to enable
the collection of multiple consistent
replicates within a given structure or
substructure these are 200 micron
circles um technically still both
profiling to some degree but i really
like this approach if you don't need to
get super granular so that you can
establish multiple replicates within a
given area and could get really fine
spatial resolution without the need for
micro dissection
we also use cell type specific
segmentation in the cortical layer rois
and also in select regions from the
catapultamen and the amygdala
in these rois we use the new end signal
to specifically segment and profile the
neuronal nuclei in each of these regions
so in the image in the the right on the
right side of the screen you can see a
zoomed in view of one of the rois from
the cotoputamen
and you can see the magenta
new end staining and then the orange
overlay of the
mask that was used to target
the new n-positive cells within the
region of interest
we also collected
what we call here the neural pill regen
from each of these
rois that was segmented
in this case we the the neural pill
contains the synaptically dense area of
tissue between the neurons
and here we also
this segment also does include some
glial cell bodies and processes
i i wanted to highlight here that we
also were able to collect from the
choroid plexus and we did so using um
sort of a combined segmentation
geometric type of approach where
instead of trying to match the fine
tracing of this very unique or
to trace this fine um
unique tissue structure
we
um
we used a geometric
shape to
designate a region of interest in each
of the ventricles and then use tissue
autofluorescence
to select only the tissue in that region
okay so
some data here to share
the plot on the left shows the total
number of genes detected throughout the
different regions profiles
each color is a different primary region
such as the thalamus or hypothalamus and
then the different shading um
the
the
the colors are shaded
to designate all of the different
subregions
uh in those rois that were segmented uh
into new and positive and neural pill
segments we see the new and positive
segments in yellow and the neural pill
segment in this sort of reddish orange
orange color that you can see
across multiple of the different regions
now as might be expected we did see more
genes detected in the neuron rich
segments across all of the regions
profiled about 10 000 genes on average
detected in each of those neuron
populations
on the right side of this slide we're
looking at a heat map of subset of
general gene sets that would be expected
to be expressed in the brain
specifically in the regions we're
looking at these gene sets and regions
collected that have been segmented into
new and positive versus neural pill
a few things to point out here
first is that in the new and positive
segments we see
an enrichment of gene sets involved in
uh like chromatin modification mrna
splicing gene sets are that are
involved in transcription translation
processes which matches what we see on
the total number of genes detected
neurons are more transcriptionally
active than
the other cell types or tissues that are
tissue areas that are profiled in this
experiment
because we did include some glial cells
were included in the neural pill
components we see an enrichment of glial
related genes in the neural pill
segments
and then
synaptic genes
as may be expected we see
an enrichment in cortex specifically
in both the new and positive and neural
pill segments
this may make sense given that we know
many of these genes are vocally
translated as synapses so we would
expect to see them in both
the new and positive and neural pill
component
uh interestingly uh sort of in the
middle of this plot we see serotonergic
synapse genes are enriched specifically
in the neural pill which may be
indicative of more locally translated
components at these
this specific synapse state
so another thing we can look at with
geometric spatial transcriptomic data
is cell type deconvolution
of the spatial data
so here we have an overview of
non-cortical rois the cortical roi
data is available on the soa website
just didn't fit directly here on this
slide
but the way that
the cell decon works is by aligning the
geomets data with pre-existing single
cell rna-seq data to identify the cell
type composition of each roi collected
so these stacked bar plots show the
proportion of each of the different cell
types referenced in this case
in the drop vis mouse frame single cell
rna-seq atlas
from this plot the differences in
choroid plexus versus the parenchyma i
think are quite striking as we would
expect with very high alignment of
choroid plexus and endothelial tip cells
in the choroid
and
more neurons and glial cells in the
parenchyma
now within the parenchyma the white
matter roi is collected
from the cortical spinal tract
these are a little bit hard to see on
the image but they are the
circles in gray that are overlaying the
um
the cyan gfap positive
area between
the
the thalamus hypothalamus on the right
side of of the image
so
these white matter rois
collected from the corticospinal tract
are very different
from those that were placed in gray
matter
we might expect we see
high numbers of oligodendrocytes
in these regions
as well as other glial cells
if we look at the new and positive
segmented rois we can see a clear
enrichment of
neurons in each of these these
populations
while the neural pill segments contain
more mixed population more glial cells
in those populations still a decent
neuronal component
again we expect to some local
translation of
neuronal genes
in the neural pill
segments as well
and then the remaining rois here are all
geometric and as we expect we see a mix
of neuron and glial cell types
so here we're looking specifically at
cortex and we can see the different
cortical rois selected on the right side
of the slide in the image
the principal components analysis on the
left side shows a nice separation of the
different segmented cell populations
with the geometric section
geometric segments in blue in the middle
clustering sort of in between
the two different segmented populations
uh mu and positive and yellow and again
the neural pill in burnt orange
so given that the geometric
segments are the sum of the two parts it
makes a lot of sense that we would
expect to see them spot in the middle
uh the boxes on the right these are
layer one
regions and these are
the cell composition of these regions is
quite different from the other cortical
layers and actually more reflects that
of the neural pill versus
anything else now
uh it's hard to see on this plot but pca
2 is actually driving some degree of
separation by cortical layer
i think this is actually nicer to look
at with the
whole cohort of four samples
so on this plot the shape is
is associated
with the population collected and that
pattern reflects exactly that which we
see on the left side
uh the pcl on the left side from the
single sample
and different colors represent the
different cortical layers so you can see
the these different cortical layers sort
of beautifully cascading down the y-axis
um
where we have we go from
layer six and a yellow to five four
three
um 3 2 and then one is kind of over
there on its own because of its unique
cell type composition
so continuing on in cortex if we look
into the new and positive rois we can
identify
neuron specific genes that are enriched
in each cortical layer
the gene clusters i think are pretty
clear on this heat map this is from this
is a heat map from the whole cohort so n
equals 4
mice
and this is a heat map of the top genes
that are differentially expressed
between the cortical layers so we look
at some of the specific genes identified
in this analysis we can find spatial
conformation
from that original spatial
transcriptomics experiment described and
published by the allen in 2006
and it can be a lot of fun to
use the allen brain atlas to spot check
geomets data but i'll just pull out a
few examples here
of
some of the key genes identified on a
region by region
basis so
here i'm showing text ii this is a
homeodomain transcription factor that's
well established to be enriched in
layers two through four it serves as a
marker of upper cortical layers and we
see that in our geomets data
i pointed the arrow shows where we see
this um
gene within our geomet uh
data set and then on the left we see
the
expression pattern from the nc2
hybridization for that gene in the allen
atlas matches very nicely
a
higher signal in the upper cortical
layers
next gene of interest
is zap b1 we see this
most highly expressed in layer four in
our data set although there's some
expression in layers five and six as
well
um and this is a
gene that is an activity modulated
transcription factor which is enriched
in in our neurons and it's established
that
layer four has a higher highest density
of inner neurons as any of the cortical
layers so it makes sense that we would
see higher expression here
a little bit hard to see on the ish
image but
you can see the the sort of granular
layer
clearly labeled and then
labeling in layer five and six
as well
the etv1 we find expression exclusively
in layer 5 and that's very clearly seen
by this in this image
the nc2 image this is a transcription
factor that's expressed in the subset of
layer 5 pyramidal neurons
we see very clean expression in both the
genomics and with the ish
and then layer six we see this gene
that's been reported as a marker of
layer six
neurons by others as well and uh this is
ighm it's
immunoglobulin constant domain gene no
one's really sure what it's doing in
layer six neurons but but it's present
and can serve as a marker of those
neuron types so we see really nice
enrichment of this gene in layer six our
geomics dataset as well
backing out of the cortex here
we can do the same type of differential
expression analysis and it can be very
useful for identifying genes expressed
by cell populations in other regions of
the brain
which can allow us to begin to associate
genes with functional behaviors
so in this example we're comparing
adjacent
new and positive segments in the
catapultamine versus the amygdala let me
zoom in a little bit here
so we see the different uh then the
neurons um that are profiled in the
catapultament outlined
here in um
purple
and the overlays are shown in orange and
then down in the
bottom of this image
the the yellow trace outlines the
amygdala
regions and the different neurons that
were profiled and those regions
are shown in orange
with the orange overlays here as well so
these are this isn't a
comparison between two directly adjacent
structures with very different
uh connectivity and
functionality within the brain
and uh we see that reflected in with
fast differences and gene expression
profiles between those two different
regions
i've highlighted some genes known to be
expressed in each
respective population profiled here such
as the excitatory synaptic regulator
c1ql that's shown enriched in the
amygdala
and expression in the basolateral
amygdala is known to be required for
normal fear memories and
then on the other side of the plot we
see
multiple genes that are associated with
dopamine transmission in the striatum
elevated these are genes that are
elevated here
in the caudoputainment which would be
expected for a striatal regen
again here just showing some
ish verification this is drd2 this is
one of the genes the gene that i shared
at the very beginning of this this
presentation
uh we can see nice expression in the
caudoputamen and none in the amygdala
we see that nicely reflected when we
look at this gene specifically in that
analysis
so we again drd2 this it would be
expected to be in the stratums so to
some degree low-hanging fruit here but
expect that there's a likely much more
novel and interesting biology that's uh
that remains in this data set to be
explored um you know here are some of
these that are labeled and also some
that are unlabeled
so
i encourage
anyone that's interested to take a look
at this data set it's all available for
download at our website
and
many of the plots that i shared here
today are put together in a really
nicely packaged step-by-step story and
this is the opening page here you can
see the table of contents
this is accessible for anyone to walk
through and really get a nice example of
a geomets experiment
from the mouse brain
now from here i'd like to jump into the
next experiment
i'll be discussing which this
essentially serves as a targeted
follow-up
genomics experiment to the spatial organ
atlas
and here uh we've worked with some
collaborators at emory who are very
interested in looking at specific neuron
populations um
and and
you know sort of atlasing these
populations to to the same degree
um from a distinct region of the brain
uh essentially we're looking at
a slightly different more rostral
coronal plane from the same type of
mouse brain
the specific neurons of interest in this
project are the spiny projection neurons
that sit within the striatum so spiny
projection neurons are a special type of
gabaergic inhibitory neuron that make up
about 95 percent of neurons within the
striatum
they're modulated by dopamine from the
substantia [ __ ] and the classical
difference between these two cell types
is that
they both control
movement
and and
essentially the direct spinal spiny
projection neurons will promote movement
via direct pathway
so
directly projecting
by directly projecting onto the
globus pallidus and uh substantia [ __ ]
uh pars articulata
uh while the
inhibit or sorry
indirect pathway spiny projection
neurons i
end
work to inhibit movement via a more
indirect pathway to the same target so
important here what's important here is
that the dsbns promote movement while
the isbns
inhibit movement
now these
two different neuron populations reside
within the striatum
which is essentially this big
light blue blob that we see on
the reference from the
anatomical
brain alice that's shown on the lower
left
side of the screen
now
interestingly unlike many of the other
structures that we identified in the
earlier experiment and that are shown on
this same coronal plane
where we see
sub-regions of within each structure
there's really no further stratification
of the striatum
on the anatomical atlas at least thus
far
really no obvious cell patterning on the
nizzle stain
on the left side of that
the split image
either however recent work has shown
that there are actually substantial
differences in connectivity and gene
expression patterns when adding
additional spatial contacts into the
striatum
and in fact it can be subdivided into
at least three functional sub-regions
so this looks something like this
where
we have the three different functional
subregions
the dorsal medial striatum receives
convergent input from associative areas
including the prelimbic area
posterior parietal association area and
the temporal association area
the dorsal medial striatum is thought to
support goal directed behavior by
representing associations between
responses and outcomes
the dorsal lateral striatum
is about to be involved in more habitual
and skilled performance and it receives
sensory motor input involving the trunk
and lower limbs
the ventral lateral
striatum also receives sensory motor
input
but for the mouse at least involving the
upper limbs and mouth
now our collaborators at emory uh dr
caitlin romano and dr ellen hess
they
sort of ambitiously wanted to
independently profile the two different
neuron populations in each of these
three striatal subregions that are shown
here
fortunately
the two different neuron populations can
be readily identified
using rna scope fluorescent nc2
hybridization probes as we can see here
in this image
so for the geomex experiment
we use the drd1
rna scope probe to identify the dspns
which are shown here in cyan
the the gray image is cyto83 this is a
nuclear same
the
ispns are identified here
using rna scope for adora 2a and this is
shown in magenta
we can see from the merged image that
these neurons are tightly packed in the
stratum but the signals don't overlap
so for each of the brains profiled for
this experiment
there are a total of six uh wild-type
c-57 black six brains profiled here uh
three male three female
for each of these brains
we
uh placed rois in each of the three
spatial sub-regions of the striatum as
are shown in the top right image so we
have dorsal medial dorsal lateral
endorse and ventral lateral
so within
for a single mouse we
looked at six different
cell postulations total
in this
region of the brain that otherwise
appears relatively homogeneous
so a quick recap here on the geomx
workflow has the same workflow as i
shared previously but in this case the
fluorescent rna scope morphology markers
were used to highlight the features of
interest in the tissue instead of
fluorescent labeled antibodies other
very minor differences were that
multiple sections were placed and
profiled on a single slide
as shown in the schematic although i
think kate was able to get
six total brain sections on a single
slide so this is a single slide um
this experiment was conducted on a
single
slide and uh
a large uh data set from a single slide
experiment
uh the other main difference is that the
the spatial organelles samples that i
described that were all ffpe these are
fresh frozen samples so
the assay will run with either either
sample type otherwise exactly the same
as shown before
the first plot uh
i'm showing here is looking at gene
expression changes in the
dspns versus the ispns
throughout the striatum this is all of
the subregions of the striatum collapse
together
over 11 000 genes were detected in um
total in this experiment
again we're only looking at two
different neuron types so it's really
a nice number of genes overall that
we're detecting
the genes that we see
in each of these populations indicate
clear enrichment for each of the
population profiled we see
canonical
i spn and dspn markers those that we
actually use for segmentation due
drd1 and azura
2a showing up on the respective sides of
the volcano plot along with
several other genes that
are known to be uh
expressed in each of the different
cell types providing a really nice
sanity check that we're
we're collecting from the
regions intended
cell types intended
moving forward with the more spatial
gene expression comparisons we first
compared
gene expression patterns in the dspns
specifically
noting 172 total significant
the
differentially expressed genes between
the dorsal medial and dorsal lateral
striatal regions
uh between the dorsal lateral and dorsal
ventral
um
sorry ventral lateral regions there were
356 differentially expressed genes
identified
looking at
the
ispns we saw a total of 76
differentially expressed genes between
the dorsal medial dorsal lateral
striatum
and
like with the
dspns we see a larger number of
differences between the dorsolateral and
ventral lateral ispns with a a large
increase in the expression of robo3 in
the ventral lateral ispns compared to
the the dorsolateral
so these data
there's that we continue to
we're continuing to work on further
analysis
for all of the work that's presented
here today
but i think both studies really speak to
the fact that the spatial trans
transcriptomic profiling methods
with dsp as shown here
really allow investigators to ask
targeted questions looking at both the
region
and cell type specific transcriptomics
throughout the brain
both of these projects today were
collected in in wild type or control
mice but
both
used approaches that could very easily
be
adapted or adopted
by investigators that are working to
investigate
different mouse models of neurological
disease or even looking into different
therapeutic trials
using mouse as a model system
so all of this work was done in about
one week total we collected about 10
sections from sample prep to sequencing
readout within
that week
and i think another important point is
that
both projects shown here today focus a
lot on profiling neurons but we've also
done a lot of work
to profile other cell type populations
within the brain such as microglia and
astrocytes so please
keep an eye on the facial organ atlas as
we continue to
release
additional stories we should see some
human brain data coming out very um
the data's there the story is coming
soon and we'll see some additional
segmentation type of approaches there
additionally i want to point out if you
have a gmx dsp and you're interested in
contributing to our social organelles
data repository please visit our website
for more information it's a great
growing
resource and we expect it will be a
tremendous resource for the spatial
biology community
with that i would like to apolo
acknowledge the whole team that worked
on the spatial organ atlas data release
at nana manastring specifically for
mouse brain
along with our fantastic collaborators
ellen hess and caitlin romano at the
emory university
school of medicine
thank you so much for your time today
well thank you allison for your
informative presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen so
let's get started
so our first question that came in for
you allison is can geomex digital
spatial profiling be used to spatially
profile protein
yeah great question absolutely
we offer neuroscience specific modules
for both
a protein modules for both mouse and
human
plant
another question that came in is can i
study other species um such as rat with
genomic csp
yeah yeah absolutely so
nanostring offers a custom probe design
and barcoding service for
up to 200 targets and
with that you can you can
design your panel specific
to your experimental question for a rat
or other
non-mouse non-human species
great another question that came in is i
see that you have a human brain data set
in the spatial organ atlas when will you
be publishing a nervous story on this
data set
yeah absolutely
the data right now for for our human
brain samples is available for download
but the story will be available
hopefully by the end of this month so so
stay tuned and definitely check that
story out i'm excited about that one too
okay
another question
that came in is from carmen with royal
college of surgeons in ireland
is there a difference in rna quality
when using ffpe versus fixed frozen
can you test rna quality prior to probe
collection
yeah um so so geomets works with ffpe
tissue fixed frozen
the
the striatum samples from the mouse
brain that we profiled for fresh frozen
so we have protocols for
all three tissue preparation types we we
do not see big differences in rna
quality um well in signal quality
from section to section with our geomex
whole transcriptome readout
sample type
the sample type with that readout and
then if you want to test the the quality
of your samples prior to probe
collection
our our assay is in nc2 hybridization
based assay so we really recommend that
you use
like a lower plex
ish assay to test the quality in such as
rna scope look at medium and low
expressors and if you can detect medium
and low expressors in your tissue of
interest you should be good to go with
using the geomex rna assays
great thank you another question that
came in is from gabriel at lcsb um did
you sort the cells for iba 1 if yes are
you missing some cells that are in the
amygdala but don't necessarily express
the marker
yeah so so
in in this specific experiment we did
not collect from the iba1 positive
cells uh so we looked specifically at
neurons
um and then the neural pill component we
have done experiments where we've looked
at microglia and have
used the combination of ibm iba1 and
team m119
for the that type of segmentation and
actually there is some microglia
specific segmentation coming in the
human story
great a couple more questions from
gabriella um
did you take into consideration patch
and matrix in the interior posterior
differences
yeah so
um
i'm not sure i don't think i ended up
including a full
image of one of those
sections that we profiled from the
striatum but essentially the same
coronal plane was used for every single
mouse so we matched the anterior
posterior position from mouse to mouse
to mouse
that were profiled there and and again
really focused on the
the dorsolateral dorsal medial and
ventrolateral components of the striatum
great another question from gabriella
how does this data compare to humans
since the structure of the striatum
differs between mice and humans
is a fantastic question so i would
really love to see some geomex data um
from human striatum to answer that
question right now i don't i don't have
a great answer i think we would really
like to see the the comparable
data from human
make a call from that
great and another question that came in
from mark
you mentioned having a human brain
transcriptive atlas as well
did you or others see any significant
differences
as have been recently shown in drg
sensory ganglia by ted price and others
yeah so for our human brain
transcriptome atlas we profiled areas of
the
cortex and hippocampus
specifically so we don't have as many
regions profiled
within that data set but we do go a
little bit deeper into the differential
expression between the different cell
types and the different given areas
all right and another question from
carmen when drawing contours
is it possible to do this in the geomix
software or does the file need to be
exported into image j
what file type ome tiff or is tiff
sufficient
yeah so we have a
contouring type script for image j that
can be used
with our software to
draw the contours so
the file type that you'll export there's
actually a specific export button
in within the user interface of the
software specifically
for
exporting the roi specific tiff files so
you don't need the ome tiff
for that
you export individual tip files run the
script import them directly back
into the software and then you can
actually visualize the the contours
directly
on your sample before you collect so if
you wanted to go back and do any
additional editing and image j
you could do that you'll see exactly
what will be collected
excellent and then we have another
question from gabriella that just came
in what is the collection protocol for
fresh frozen samples how do you
dissociate the tissue my concern is
always that i miss some cells that are
more sensitive to damage
yeah so so i mean one of the nice things
about the the genomics workflow is that
it's it's non-destructive to your tissue
so
um we do
fix the tissue
we do fix fresh frozen tissue actually
overnight before we proceed with our
sample preparation which is a pretty
standard nc2 hybridization
preparation
and ms leaves
the tissue really nicely intact you can
adjust your proteinase concentration
kind of depending on your concerns of
for your specific sample type but
in our experience that initial fixation
is robust and allows
moving forward with the processing of
most stable types
excellent well thank you so much allison
so um does anyone else have any more
questions that they didn't get a chance
to answer um now is the time
all right well that concludes our q a
session for today's webinar
um do you have any more final comments
for our audience allison
um i don't think so thank you all so
much for your your time and attention
it's it's really exciting to get to
share some of this
neurospecific geomets data with the
greater community
thank you
so thanks everyone for your time today
and thanks alison for presenting this
research and before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and further engaging questions
questions that we didn't have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast uh
will be available on demand for two
years um until march of 2024
um labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and that is it and
that concludes the nana sharing webinar
for labyrinth neuroscience 2022 thanks
everyone and we'll see you next time
thank you
you